Okay, so welcome back to the desk. So that
was the dark world of technical analysis
and price action indicators. All you have
to do, guys, is remember a few things when
it comes to TA and PA. It's really not
that complicated. Just remember, firstly,
that the picture that you're looking at on
the screen is a photograph.
of the fundamentals behind price. Okay.
Secondly, we use TA and PA as indicators
to help us make decisions for timing only.
So we add value to our executions for both
entry and exit for positions. Okay. The
advantage that they give us is helping us
to add value to our executions for entry
and exit for positions. Okay. The
advantage that they give us is helping us
to add value to our executions for entry
and exit for positions. Okay. The
advantage that they give us is helping us
to add value to our executions for entry
and exit for positions. Okay.
entry and exit, and therefore are timing
only for our ideas. So ideas that we
already have in place
with a directional, fundamental
predisposition or bias. Technical analysis
and price action
is just not rocket science, and they do
not generate trade ideas. It has its place
in our
process, and it's for timing only. So what
do we do if we are concerned about our
timing on entry?
Well, we just sit back and we wait for a
better level. It's down to our discretion,
so it's down
to your discretion now in the future. So
now we're going to move on to the next
part of the video
series. And in this video, and in the next
video, we have actually a lot of ground to
cover. And we're
going to be covering psychology in trading
and preventative risk management. So PRM,
okay? Now,
when it comes to PRM, we're not going to
literally set you risk management rules or
parameters that you
have to stick to and abide by at all
times. That would just be really, really
silly. Why? Because
you have to learn to do this for yourself
in practice, and risk management is
actually flexible. Plus,
risk management in a long-short equities
portfolio mandate has an endless amount of
permutations,
and it's really situational to your own
portfolio that you build, okay? You're
going to discover this
and more as we go through particularly
this video, but also the next video as
well. In the video after
this, Chris Quill is going to go through
various PRM measures that you can put in
place by modeling the
measures in a model portfolio. So this is
so you can understand them, why they exist
in the first place, and also so you can
actually calculate them properly. So at
this stage, you can begin to make your own
decisions at which preventative
risk management measures you will put in
place for your own purposes, okay? To suit
your own portfolio. And you'll be able to
do that in the
in the future when you're doing it in
practice. So we're going to go through all
of them. Okay, so let's get stuck into
trading
psychology and PRM, preventative risk
management, and I'll see you back at the
desk a bit later.
Okay, so welcome back to the screen. We're
going to move into the next stage of the
PTM video series now, and we're going to
be looking at
trading psychology and preventative risk
management. Specifically, what we're going
to do here is do the
groundwork and lay the foundations to get
your head right before you start trading
live. So part of this
video is actually going to be quite fun to
go through. You'll probably recognize a
lot of behaviors that you've
experienced yourself in the past. But the
messages are actually very important. And
you do need to walk away
from this video fully understanding what
we're trying to get across here. Because
if you don't, it can be
extremely costly with real money losses in
a very short space of time. And also
missing out and
potentially not experiencing in your
trading very big gains. So before we get
started, we have to put into
context here and have a reminder of the
pro trader systematic process for long
short portfolio management
in the 20 to 60 day time horizon. So we
have our fundamentals, our quant and our
qualitative processes.
We have our timing and our catalysts and
trade structure. And then we have finally
our risk management.
And our risk management only really comes
into play when we're either about to have
a live portfolio, or we actually do
have live positions. And risk management
essentially splits up into two parts.
Preventative risk management and reactive
risk management.
Preventative risk management is all of the
things that we put in place before we
actually have a live position in a stock,
long or short, or before we have a live
portfolio.
And reactive risk management is when we
actually have a live position in a stock,
long or short, or we actually have a live
portfolio with real positions.
And again, when it comes to our time
horizon, we must never forget that a trade
idea is not an investment idea, nor is it
a day trade.
Remember, we are 20 to 60 day long short
portfolio managers. We want to run
positions long enough to take advantage of
a trading volatility profile, but we don't
want to run positions long enough or too
long that they end up becoming
investments.
And this is important to remember,
especially when it comes to your risk
management as a long short portfolio
manager or trader.
So where do we start in terms of getting
our heads right?
Well, when we have a trade idea that's
actionable, it means that we have the
fundamental tailwind behind us, whether
that's a long or a short.
We have our catalyst in place, we have our
catalyst in place, and we have timing
that's balanced in our favor, and we have
chosen our trade structure.
And as I've mentioned several times prior
in the PTM video series, we're only going
to be looking at the trade structure of
long or short stock or CFDs in the video
series.
And we're not going to be looking at
options positions, so directional call
option and directional put option
structures.
So when we refer to stocks in this video,
if you're in the US, we're referring to
stocks in a trading account where you
actually have 50% margin requirements or
two times leverage.
And if you're sitting outside the United
States with international trading accounts
in the rest of the world context, what
we're meaning here is contract for
differences.
So CFDs on stocks.
We cover options structuring in the
professional options trading masterclass
video series.
And learning how to structure options
trades is an entire discipline in itself,
and it requires a lot of educational
information and learning.
The theory for options structuring is
available in the POTM video series, and
it's important to get live experience
trading options over a long period of time
over many trades.
And that is essentially covered in the
ITPM mentoring programs.
So what we do in the PTM video series is
assume that you have a trade idea in a
stock, whether that's long or short, and
you express this idea via a long or short
position in the stock itself.
Of course, when you get more sophisticated
and learn more about trading and graduate
to options trading, you can express those
positions utilizing call and put option
structures.
However, it is only right to do so if you
have a directional view on the underlying
stock.
So for the purposes of discipline here in
the PTM video series, we are going to
assume that you have a view in the stock.
So a trade idea, long or short, and you're
representing this with a position in the
stock itself or in a contract for
difference, which mirrors one for one this
underlying stock price.
So with that assumption in place, when we
have a fundamental tailwind with us, we
have our catalysts and we have what we
believe to be decent or good timing.
So we have a green light with the
technicals and the price action.
And we've actually chosen our trade
structure.
It's time to have a stock position, long
or short.
So at this stage, it's now time to think
about risk management.
And as we mentioned previously, risk
management splits up into two categories.
Preemptive risk management, PRM and
reactive risk management, RRM.
And what we're going to be looking at here
in the PTM video series is preemptive risk
management.
For reactive risk management, you actually
have to have a live position.
And when a position goes right or wrong,
there's literally an endless amount of
things that you can do, an endless amount
of actions that you can take on that
position.
And unfortunately, there is no rule book
for reactive risk management.
There's just multiple best practices.
And these cannot be taught in a video
series.
They have to be taught live.
And the way this is done at ITPM is via
our mentoring programs.
Reactive risk management can't be taught
in some sort of user guide or manual.
Reactive risk management just has to be
taught with live positions and having a
pro trader sitting on your shoulder and
literally overseeing what you're doing.
So in the PTM video series, we're going to
be covering preemptive risk management.
But why do we have any of this in place to
begin with?
Well, prior to learning our long short
portfolio management techniques, our risk
management, you have to first understand
why these parameters, these risk
management parameters are necessary.
So the real question is here is why do we
even have preventative risk management?
What are we trying to actually prevent?
Well, we're obviously trying to prevent
unnecessary losses and the parameters are
necessary because of human psychology.
Or putting it another way, the failings or
weaknesses of human psychology when it
comes to trading and money management.
The reality is, is that once you decide a
trade idea is actionable, then moments
from that time, you are going to have a
real and live long or short stock
position.
And the stock will actually be moving.
Now, as we are located in the 20 to 60 day
time horizon, and we choose our annualized
portfolio volatility to be around 20%.
It means that most of our single stock
positions are going to likely have upwards
of 30% annualized volatility.
And there will definitely be some with
much higher than 30% annualized
volatility.
And even though, of course, we strive to
have low correlation across our positions
in our portfolio, there is going to still
be some correlation.
And due to this correlation effect within
a diverse long short stock portfolio, the
overall annualized volatility of the
portfolio will be lower than the
volatility of any single stock position in
the portfolio.
And if you recall, Chris Quill covered
this in the previous section of the PTM
video series Foundations of Portfolio
Management, and he will go deeper into
this and further add to it in the next
section of the video series via more
spreadsheet classes.
But the reality is when we have live
portfolios, we're going to have situations
all the time as traders where things go
our way.
So things go right and things go against
us or go wrong with live positions.
So we anticipate this.
We absolutely expect this to be the case
before we even have a position or a live
portfolio.
So prior to going live, you have to
understand human psychology.
You have to get your psychology right as a
trader and therefore you need to get your
head right.
So what we're going to do here by way of
an example is we're going to get your head
right.
We're going to play a game and we're going
to trade marbles and I am going to trade
marbles against you.
And we're going to put ourselves into this
hypothetical scenario scenario one where I
am paying you.
So you are getting paid.
And this is a one shot game.
So you only have one attempt at this game.
Just one chance.
Now there are two boxes with marbles in
them.
There is box A and box B.
In box A, there's a total of four marbles
and there are three blue marbles and one
red marble making up those four marbles.
And in box B, there's just one marble and
that marble is green.
Now you are putting your hand in the
boxes.
So you have a choice.
Box A or box B.
If you put your hand in box A and pull out
a blue marble, I pay you $1,000.
If you put your hand in box A and pull the
red marble, I pay you nothing.
If you choose to put your hand in box B,
well, there's only one green marble and
that pays $700.
And obviously, before you put your hand in
boxes, you know what the marble situation
is in each box.
So you know, for example, in box B, that
there's only one green marble.
So if you put your hand in box B and you
pull the green marble, you get paid $700.
So the question is, which box do you
choose?
Which box do you put your hand in?
Do you choose box A or do you choose box
B?
I'll give you a few moments to decide.
Okay, so that's enough time, I think, to
make a decision.
Now let's move on to the next scenario,
scenario two.
We have the same situation with the two
boxes, but now you are paying me.
So you are paying out, but you are still
putting your hand in either of the boxes.
It's you, not me.
So if you put your hand in box A and you
pull a blue marble, you pay me $1,000.
If you put your hand in box A and pull the
red marble, you pay me nothing.
If you put your hand in box B, well,
there's only one marble.
You have to pay me $700.
So I'll give you a few moments to think
again.
In the situation where you're paying me,
do you choose box A or do you choose box
B?
Okay, so you should have had enough time
there.
Hopefully, you've decided by now what
action you would have taken in scenario
one when you are getting paid and in
scenario two when you're paying out.
So when you're paying me.
So let's go through this.
Typically, what we have found and you'll
see this time and time again in either
survey responses or in a live setting in a
room with a few hundred retail traders.
Is that in scenario one where people are
getting paid that tends to be a 70% 30%
split in favor of box B.
And sometimes it's even as high as an
80-20 split in favor of box B.
So the majority of people, majority of
retail traders tend towards box B in
scenario one when getting paid.
In scenario two in which you are paying
me, crowds of retail traders tend to
always skew towards box A
disproportionately.
And sometimes we do get an 80-20 split in
favor of box A, but it's actually usually
90-10 in favor of box A.
And a lot of times in survey responses or
in a live setting in a room that's full of
retail traders, a lot of respondents will
choose box A for both scenarios or even
box B for both scenarios.
So there's an overlap in their choices
depending on the scenario.
But overwhelmingly, most retail traders
who do choose the same box will choose box
A twice.
And in this situation, in both scenarios,
if they've chosen the same box, well,
nothing has changed with the boxes.
It's the same payout.
So the psychology of those respondents is
actually totally screwed up.
So let's have a look at the first
scenario, getting paid.
Well, scenario one, getting paid, you're
facing a positive dollar outcome.
So if we think about what box A and box B
represent, they can be described as risk
for box A and certainty for box B.
And when faced with a positive outcome,
human beings tend towards certainty.
Humans like certainty when they're getting
paid.
In trading, this means taking profits too
quickly.
Overall, human beings tend to focus too
much on locking in profits because it's a
comfortable feeling.
What we have to do as traders is focus on
letting our profits run.
And this is an uncomfortable feeling.
So the right answer from a trader's
perspective for scenario one, getting
paid, is box A.
We have to seek risk and move away from
certainty.
We have to seek to allow our profits to
run.
And we have to accept that risk exists and
possibly even take more risk by adding
more capital to a winning position.
So when times are good, when we're making
money, we have to seek out risk.
Now, what about in scenario two, where
you're still putting your hand in the
boxes to choose the marbles, but from your
choice, you are now paying me.
So this scenario we call paying out.
This is when you're facing a negative
dollar outcome.
And when faced with a negative outcome,
human beings tend towards risk-seeking
behavior.
Humans don't like taking losses.
Humans are averse to losses naturally.
Humans want a chance at having no losses,
no matter how small that chance is.
And in trading, this means holding on to
losing positions for too long instead of
taking a guaranteed loss.
And for humans, taking a guaranteed loss
is naturally an uncomfortable feeling.
The natural human reaction is to choose to
hold on to a losing position and do
nothing and hope that we get out of it for
nothing.
This is the comfortable feeling.
So in this situation, when times are bad,
when we're paying out, when we're losing
money, like in the scenario when we're
getting paid, we have to understand our
human psychology and natural human
condition.
When we're losing, when we're losing, when
we're losing, when we're paying out, we
have to understand the human condition,
human psychology, and we have to
understand that capital is a finite
parameter.
It's limited.
Therefore, we have to seek to restrict
losses to guaranteed outcomes and
therefore preserve our capital.
We can't simply hold on to losing
positions forever, engage in this negative
behavior repeatedly, and then our capital
goes to zero and we blow up.
So in the scenario of paying out, the
right answer is box B.
Now, if you recall, in both our examples
of the scenarios, getting paid and paying
out, this was a one shot game.
You had one attempt, but now assume an
infinite amount of trades in our lifetime.
So we're not just playing this game once,
we're playing it an infinite amount of
times.
Well, whether you play this game once or
whether you play it an infinite amount of
times, it doesn't matter.
The probabilistic payout, the probability
adjusted payout of risk.
So box A is the same.
And of course, we know the payout of box
B, that was simply $700.
That is certain.
What's not certain is box A, which
presents us with risk.
And on a probability adjusted basis, the
payout of box A is $750.
So it's higher.
And because these numbers are quite close
together, as 750 for box A and 700 for box
B, this tends to confuse people in their
responses.
So imagine if you magnified the numbers so
there's a bigger difference between them.
So this example does tend to cause
confusion because the numbers are quite
close together.
But if you magnify these numbers so the
difference is larger, it becomes really
obvious.
So when you look at this in trading and in
human psychology, what does it actually
mean?
Well, it means when we're looking at our
portfolio and let's say we have a 10 stock
portfolio with six longs and four shorts.
And at the moment in time that we're
looking at the portfolio, we have five
winners and five losers.
So we have five positions that are making
money and five positions that are
currently losing money.
Well, a human would naturally tend towards
the behavior of increasing the position
sizes of all their losers or just not do
anything.
But if they are increasing the position
sizes of their losers, they would
essentially be looking to improve their
average price so they feel that they have
a better chance of getting out, not losing
money.
What are they doing in this situation?
They are seeking more risk and pulling
from box A when they are in a losing
position.
So they're pulling from box A in the
scenario where they're paying out.
They are paying out to the market.
And on the flip side, in the other
situation, when we have a winner and we're
getting paid, what do humans tend towards?
Well, humans in that situation, when
getting paid, tend towards certainty.
So in trading, this means human behavior
tends towards taking profits on winners
too quickly because it feels comfortable.
So if these actions are being taken
repeatedly over an infinite amount of
trades over an infinite amount of time,
what's the likely outcome of this
portfolio?
Well, the trader is just going to end up
with a portfolio of losing positions
because they're trading out of their
winners and putting more money into their
losers or actually just doing nothing with
their losers.
And the losing positions will likely
continue to keep losing.
And even if they're doing nothing with
their losers, they're not even adding to
their positions.
Well, they're selling their winners.
They're raising cash.
And that cash in the next cycle of trade
ideas is just going to go into losers and
winners.
The winners will get traded out of and the
losers will keep losing.
So eventually, no matter how long it
takes, that trader is going to blow up.
A real trader would do the opposite of
this.
A trader would cut their losers and pull
from box B and get certainty in a losing
position or when they're paying out to the
market.
And they would engage in capital
preservation and they would take the money
and add it to their winners or even just
run their winners.
And in that situation, running winners is
pulling from box A and this is seeking
more risk.
So the big lesson in psychology here of
humans versus traders, what do you
actually have to do in trading?
Well, you have to train yourself into the
behaviors of being a trader and train
yourself out of the behaviors of being a
human.
And this is something that for most people
doesn't come overnight.
It takes a lot of real money and real
world practice and experience to get used
to this.
As mentioned previously in scenario one,
getting paid, most respondents respond by
putting their hand and choosing to pull
from box B.
And in scenario two, when paying out, an
overwhelming majority of respondents tend
towards pulling from box A.
And this is simply the human condition.
And it's obviously nothing to be ashamed
of because it actually just means you are
human, which in most cases is a positive.
It's a good thing.
But unfortunately, in trading, it's a bad
thing.
And we can actually highlight this with a
great example with an interview question
that we always gave at Goldman Sachs.
This is a question we would always ask all
the time in interviews to graduates hoping
to get a position on the trading desk in
London at Goldman Sachs for when they left
university.
So the question is, let's assume we've
hired you.
You've actually been hired at Goldman
Sachs and you're now part of the trading
desk.
You're hired.
You are trading money live on the trading
desk at Goldman Sachs as part of the
business.
And your job as a trader is very obviously
to make money.
So given that you're now a professional
trader and you're sitting on the desk at
Goldman Sachs, let's go through a real
life example.
And in each scenario, you have to tell me
what action you would take.
So here we have a random stock in the year
2019.
And it doesn't matter what stock it is.
It doesn't matter what the name is.
We just want to know after you've entered
this position what your action is going to
be in each scenario.
So let's make the assumption that you're
going long here and you have the
fundamental tailwinds.
You've done all of your work on the quant
and qualitative.
You're feeling very confident about your
fundamental work.
You've got your catalysts in place.
Your technicals and price action
indicators are showing a green light and
you've gone long the stock.
And if you look at the screen here where
the red arrow is, we're going to assume
that you've gone long the stock on that
day and you are in at the price of the
yellow line.
So from the screen, this looks like you're
in at $116.
And the stock is up since you bought it
five trading days ago.
So the stock is now at $120 and two cents.
You are in at $116.
So you're up around $4 a share and
everything is looking quite nice.
And the date today when the stock is at
$120 is the 29th of November, 2019.
So in this situation, we're obviously
doing okay here.
We're getting paid.
But if we fast forward to the beginning of
2020, the stock is now trading at $133.49.
So let's say $133 and a half.
The question is, in this scenario, what
would you do?
What's your action?
And there's only three things that you can
actually do.
You can either trade out.
You can run the current position without
actually doing anything.
Or you can add to the position.
So which one do you actually choose?
Okay.
So think about that for a moment.
Which choice do you make?
Okay.
So you've probably made your choice by
now.
Let's move on to the next time horizon.
So we go a month later and we are now in
the first week of February 2020.
And the stock is now $116.45.
So we'll just call it 116 and a half.
Given the choice that you made in January.
Whether you traded out.
Whether you run the position.
Or whether you even added to the position.
What would you actually do now?
Well, if you'd have traded out in January,
you'd actually have no position.
So you'd be sitting there quite relaxed.
But you do have choices.
If you've traded out of the position.
You can either do nothing.
Or do something.
Doing something means buying stock at the
current level.
If you decided to run the position.
You now have some choices.
You can either trade out of the position.
You can either do nothing with the
position.
Or you can add to the position.
And this is actually the same set of
choices.
If you chose in January to add to the
position as well.
So based on your own individual decisions
in January.
What is your decision now?
What is the action you're going to take?
I'll give you a few moments to think about
that.
Okay, now that you've decided your next
action.
Let's fast forward just a few more days.
Not a month.
But just a few more days.
And now it's the 7th of February 2020.
And the stock is trading at $111.55.
So it's now below your cost at $116.
If you've run the position throughout.
And just maintained the same position.
Additionally, if in January.
Or on the 3rd of February.
You actually added to your position.
You initiated a position.
The price that you've entered.
Is higher than the November price.
Of $116.
So on the 7th of February.
Like the guy.
Who took the position in November.
At $116.
You still have a position.
You're in the game.
And now you're underwater.
On the 7th of February.
Now at this stage of the game.
At this stage of the example.
If you are one of those people.
That did trade out.
In January.
Or on the 3rd of February.
You are no longer.
Now in the game.
So the only people.
Watching this example.
Right now.
That are still in this game.
Are the people.
Who have a position.
And that's either.
Going to be.
Somebody.
Who initiated the position.
In November.
At $116.
Who chose to run the position.
And then didn't take any action.
In January.
Or February the 3rd.
Or.
It's going to be somebody.
Who added.
To the position.
In January.
Or.
Re-initiated.
A position.
On the 3rd of February.
It doesn't really matter.
But.
For the purposes.
Of this game.
We just have to understand.
At this stage.
Who's in.
The game.
And who's out.
If you've traded out.
At this stage.
You are out of the game.
If you still have a position.
You are still.
In the game.
So.
If you are one of those guys.
That's still in the game.
Uh.
You still have a position.
You now have.
Three.
Choices.
You can either.
Run the position.
Add.
To the position.
Or you can either.
Cut.
The position.
What's your choice.
You have to choose.
One action.
I'll leave you.
A few moments.
To decide.
And.
Okay.
So if you.
Cut.
The position.
And that was your choice.
That was the choice.
Of the action.
That you've taken.
Uh.
You are now.
Officially.
Out of this game.
If you.
Chose.
To either.
Run the position.
Or.
Add.
To the position.
You are still.
In the game.
Where you're running.
Your position.
Let's fast forward.
To the.
21st.
Of February.
And now.
The stock.
Is a hundred and six dollars.
And eleven cents.
But if you're still.
In the game.
You have.
Three.
Choices.
You can either.
Run.
Your current.
Position.
Uh.
You can.
Add.
To the position.
Or.
You can.
Cut.
The position.
You have to make.
One choice.
Okay.
If you cut.
To the position.
You are now.
Out of the game.
Uh.
If you chose.
To run.
The position.
Or.
Add.
To the position.
You are still.
In.
This game.
Okay.
Now.
We fast forward.
A few more.
Weeks.
To the third.
Of March.
And the stock.
Is now.
Seventy eight dollars.
And nineteen cents.
And if you're still.
In the game.
You have.
Three choices.
You can.
Either run.
The position.
You can.
Add.
To the position.
Or.
You can.
Cut.
The position.
I'll.
Leave.
You a few.
Moments.
To decide.
Okay.
So.
If you.
Cut.
The position.
You are.
Now.
Out.
Or.
Add.
The position.
You are.
Still.
In the game.
And now.
We're.
Going to.
Fast forward.
A few.
More.
Weeks.
To the.
Thirteenth.
Of March.
If you're.
To the.
Still.
In the game.
Do you.
Add.
To the position.
Or.
Do you.
Cut.
Again.
I'll.
Leave.
You a few.
Moments.
To decide.
On that.
Well.
If you've.
Decided.
To.
To run.
The position.
Or.
Add.
To the position.
You're.
Still.
In the game.
If we.
Fast forward.
To the.
23rd.
Of March.
The stock.
Is now.
$28.
And.
19 cents.
If you're.
Still.
In the game.
You're.
Again.
Faced.
With.
Three.
Actions.
You can.
Well.
If you've.
Decided.
To.
Cut.
You're.
Out of the game.
Now.
If you decided.
To.
Run.
The position.
You are.
Of course.
Still.
In the game.
And now.
We're going.
To.
Fast forward.
An entire.
Year.
And see.
Where the stock.
Ended up.
One year.
Later.
The stock.
Is at.
A price.
Of.
A hundred.
And sixteen dollars.
As you can see.
From the chart.
The high.
For the entire.
Year.
Was.
Just shy.
Of a hundred dollars.
So in the high.
Ninety dollars.
Around the ninety eight dollar.
Ninety nine dollar.
Level.
But the point here.
Is.
If you'd have taken.
The action.
Taken the choice.
To continuously.
Run the position.
At.
Each of those times.
With the choices.
Of.
Run the position.
Add to the position.
Or cut.
If you'd have made.
That choice.
To run the position.
You'd still be.
One year later.
Underwater.
And losing money.
On the position.
Now.
If you'd have chosen.
At.
Various points.
To add.
To the position.
On the way down.
Down.
If you'd have added.
In February.
Or early March.
You would still be.
Underwater.
And losing money.
On the position.
Because your.
Average price.
Would be higher.
Than where the stock.
Is trading.
One year later.
If you'd have added.
To the position.
In mid.
To late.
March.
At those times.
When I presented you.
With the choices.
When the stock.
Was at.
Thirty two dollars.
And at.
Twenty eight dollars.
You might.
Actually be.
At.
Your average price.
Breakeven.
One year later.
At around.
Eighty dollars.
But the point is.
Here.
If you'd have made.
Those choices.
You will have.
Had to have ridden.
A lot of risk.
For a long time.
Taken a big.
Drawdown.
In your portfolio.
On a mark.
To market basis.
And you would have.
Literally.
Had to have.
Hold on.
For an entire year.
Just.
To break.
Even.
You.
Now.
When it comes to this.
As a.
Goldman Sachs.
Interview question.
Well.
If you'd have.
Made.
Either of those.
Choices.
To run.
The position.
Or even.
Keep.
Adding.
To the position.
All the way.
Down.
Unfortunately.
There'd be a serious.
Question mark.
Over.
Whether your.
Instincts.
As a trader.
Are good.
And also.
Therefore, unless other areas of your
interview, all other areas of your
interview were absolutely exceptional,
which if you'd have given those answers is
probably unlikely, then unfortunately, you
just wouldn't be hired.
You wouldn't even be considered. And
categorically, if you were actually a
professional trader on the desk and you
took those actions, either running the
position all the way down and hoping for
the best or continuously adding to the
position all the way down, that would
actually be a sackable offense.
At a company like Goldman Sachs, you'd
simply be fired. And just for the record,
that stock, I know we didn't name the
stock earlier because it didn't really
matter because that situation applies to
all stocks.
But the stock in question was actually the
cruise lining company, Royal Caribbean,
going into the COVID crisis.
However, as mentioned, it doesn't really
matter what the stock is called or even
the specific situation.
This applies to all stocks and all
situations throughout time as a trader.
And this is exactly why we have risk
management and specifically PRM,
preventative risk management.
Why? Because it stops us from being human
and it makes us engage in all of the good
practices of being an actual trader.
And one of the most basic things we can do
as traders is to implement stop losses,
meaning that if a stock trades at a
certain level against us, we guarantee
that we only lose a certain amount of
money.
We get stopped out.
And this is what's known as a hard stop
loss.
A hard stop loss guarantees our downside.
And in our marble trading game, this is
pulling from box B.
When we have a hard stop loss in place and
we guarantee our downside and we're
pulling from box B, this is when we are
paying out to the market.
So when we're losing money, this action
stops us from being human and seeking out
more risk.
Now, what is also a typical thing to do as
a trader is not just to have some sort of
stop loss in place, but to also have a
target.
So when we're making money, when we are
getting paid by the market, we have to
have a plan or process in place to deal
with that situation.
And unlike the situation where we have
hard stop loss in place, when we're losing
money or paying out to the market, when
we're getting paid by the market, so
making money, we don't have a hard target.
We have what's called a soft target.
So we use soft targets so we don't limit
our upside.
So we are pulling from box A when we're
getting paid by the market and making
money.
As we know, human beings, when we're being
paid, when we're making money, it feels
comfortable to lock in the profit too
early.
And having a soft target stops us from
this human behavior.
So specifically, what do we mean by a soft
target?
Well, let's have a look at an example
here.
So let's say we bought a stock at $100 and
we decided that a sensible stop loss is
92.
So if the stock traded at 92, we would
just trade out of the position and take an
$8 loss per share.
So we have a hard stop loss at $92.
And then we have a soft target or target
price one of $125, which is roughly three
times the amount of the stop loss.
Now, let's say the stock then does
actually go to $125.
What is the action that we take next?
Well, as long as the fundamentals are
still in place and at $125, we still
believe that there's potentially more
upside here.
We wouldn't limit ourselves to making just
$25 per share because it feels good to
lock in that number.
What we would typically do is roll up the
stop loss to a level something like $117.
So that would be $8 below the current
price of $125 a share.
And if you then actually did get stopped
out at $117, you would still make $17 per
share on the trade.
Now, that's the situation if you just ran
the original position.
But what if you actually decided to add to
the position and take even more risk?
Well, just back of the envelope
calculation here.
If you doubled the size of your position
at $125, your new average price per share
will be $112.50.
And even in that situation, with a new
stop loss rolled up at $117, if you did
get stopped out, you would still make
$4.50 per share.
So you're still making a profit.
And if it does actually continue going up,
which if it's a winner and the fundamental
news flow is coming through with the
catalysts, if it does continue going up,
which is most likely in that situation,
you're now going to make double profit for
every tick that the stock goes up.
So for every penny or dollar that the
stock goes up for every tick, you're now
making double because you've doubled the
position size.
And the stock could just continue going
higher to say $135, $140, $145, and then
this would end up being a big winner in
your portfolio.
Now, of course, when we're going through
examples like this, please don't take this
to mean that in every situation that
you're involved in, this is exactly what
you should be doing.
This is obviously not a rulebook.
These are simply examples to help you
understand some best behaviors and best
practices that you would engage in to not
engage in human behavior.
Every situation needs to be taken on its
own merits.
And this, over time, just builds up with
experience.
So don't think this is all a blanket rule
that you have to apply to all situations
all the time throughout your career.
It simply isn't.
There isn't a rulebook.
Now, when it comes to risk management,
something else we should be covering and
discussing here is risk-reward ratios.
So in this example that we just went
through, it's not a coincidence that we
selected a hard stop-loss of $8 and a soft
target of $25 because this actually
provides us a risk-reward of just over 3
to 1.
So in this example, it's the forecasted
profit, the soft target on the upside, $25
over the guaranteed loss of $8 in being
stopped out, which gives a risk-reward of
the trade of $3.125.
And this, in trading, is known as an
R-score.
It's the ratio of the dollars made on
winners divided by the dollars made on
losers.
So if you did hundreds of trades, for
example, you would take all of the gains,
all of the dollar gains from all of the
winners and divide it by all of the dollar
losses of the losers to obtain an overall
R-score as a trader.
But the definition does apply to a single
trade as well when you're going into the
trade and having preventative risk
management.
So if the volatility exists and the soft
target is realistic and the hard stop is
at a sensible level, what do we mean by
sensible?
So when we're taking positions in single
stocks, we mean that the stop itself is
wide enough given the volatility of the
stock in our time horizon to give you a
good chance at making money and being
right.
But at the same time, it's not so wide
that you're being irresponsible and you're
being totally dishonest in your approach.
So when we're taking positions in single
stocks in the 20 to 60 day time horizon,
in most cases, we are going to be seeking
before we go in to assess the volatility
and have some sort of soft target and stop
loss in place.
Now, we don't necessarily have hard stop
losses in place all the time.
So when entering a trade, hard stops and
soft targets, if we've decided a hard stop
is the way we want to go, we must always
enter a situation in which our soft target
is realistic and probable within the 20 to
60 day time horizon.
And by the same token, our hard stop
losses must be wide enough to give
ourselves a chance of making money, but
not wide enough that we're being ill
disciplined and allowing ourselves to be
human.
So in the 20 to 60 day time horizon, we
assess volatility.
And if we decide that we're going to have
a hard stop loss or some sort of stop loss
in place on a trade structure and of
course, having a soft target, it must be
in the bounds of reality.
And therefore, within the bounds of
volatility over the time horizon and we're
seeking generally to set a one to three
ratio on pretty much all trade structures.
Firstly, if we take this approach and we
want to get paid at least three times what
we pay out to the market, then we're not
going to enter trades that don't provide
us with at least this outcome as a
probable payoff.
Finally, just by the very nature of the
numbers, we know going into a situation
where we try to apply this ratio within
the bounds of volatility all the time.
But if we trade out of all of our winners
at target prices and all of our losers at
the stop loss prices, then our dollar
ratio between winners and losers across
multiple trades in our trading account
will be three times.
So, for example, on a $100,000 account
over, say, 200 trades, we can make, say,
$264,595 on our winners by pulling from
box A and running the winner to the target
price.
And we can lose on our losers, say,
$83,548 on those losers, so pulling from
box B at the stop loss prices.
And in this situation, the R score in our
portfolio is going to be 3.17.
So, there's a very nice and comfortable,
quite large difference between what we
make on our winners and what we lose on
our losers.
And essentially, what's happening here
over 200 trades is that the $83,548 of
losses are inventory in our trading
accounts that allow us to make the profits
of $264,595.
So, we know that we're not going to get
all of our trades right.
No one ever has a win rate of 100%, very
obviously.
We go into this with our eyes wide open,
and we have a realistic approach, and we
just accept that we're going to have
losers in our portfolio.
But our losers, we see them as necessary
inventory to enable us to make money
overall.
What we don't want is a situation where
one position or two positions over a long
period of time and many trades become
significant losses and wipe out our
profits.
Losses are inevitable.
They're going to happen in trading, in
financial markets.
We just have to take an approach where we
contain them and stop us from being human.
Now, thirdly, it takes the pressure off us
in not requiring a high win rate
percentage in order to actually make
money.
So, we have a low break-even threshold
when we apply the 1 to 3 ratio within the
bounds of volatility of the time horizon.
So, in our example of a $100,000 account
with, say, 200 trades, this would actually
mean 50 trades being winners and hitting
our targets, so 25% win rate, and 150
trades being losers and hitting stop
losses, so 75% for our loss rate in order
to satisfy the condition of breaking even.
Now, in this situation, if we do actually
get more than 25%, so we have a win rate
percentage that's higher than 25%, we will
be making money.
And certainly, throughout those 200 trades
being executed, if we add to our winners
and engage in that behavior, and they pay
even more dollars than the difference
between entry price and soft target, then
we can, in theory, get less than 25% of
our trades right.
So, when we think about what this 1 to 3
risk-reward ratio means, with a target
R-score of 3, our dollar wins are 3 times
our dollar losses.
So, over 4 trades, 1 win plus 3 losses
equals 0 or break-even, therefore, 75% of
trades can be losers, while 25% can be
winners to break even.
And we can apply this formula to our
previous example, where we had a
risk-reward of $25 for the target, divided
by 8, and we got an R-score of 3.125.
So, 1 trade is a win of $25, and 3 trades
can be losers at $8 at a 3.125 R-score.
So, there's 4 trades in total.
1 winner over 4 is a quarter, so 25% for
the win rate, and 3 over 4 is 3 quarters,
or 75%, and that gives us our loss rate.
And these are the conditions that satisfy
our break-even condition.
When using a 1 to 3 risk-reward ratio
applied to stocks within our time horizon
of, say, 20 to 60 days, and are in the
bounds of volatility, and set at realistic
and sensible levels.
So, as a reminder, if we just go back one
page, setting this 1 to 3 ratio on trade
structures, whether it's single stocks or
options, is just a good discipline for
those reasons.
So, firstly, preventative risk management.
We go in to the stock, we do a volatility
appraisal, and we want to apply the 1 to 3
condition.
If the stock volatility shows us that this
is possible, and we can set realistic soft
targets and sensible stop losses,
then having this condition satisfied can
only be a good thing.
Additionally, if we're treating this as a
business, and we are realistic that losses
are inevitable,
then purely from a business perspective,
running an inventory of losses that are
contained to enable us to make money on
our winners is also a responsible
approach.
And then, finally, it takes the pressure
off us in requiring a very high win
percentage.
So, we know, going into it, that if we
have a significantly higher win rate
percentage than 25%,
we're going to be doing very well and
making very good money.
So, we understand human psychology, and we
understand the bad behaviors that we don't
want to engage in.
We approach trading and our trading
accounts as a business, and we accept that
throughout time, losses will occur,
and also, we will get trades wrong, and we
apply PRM preventative risk management
practices to enable us overall to make
money over many trades throughout time.
Now, the burning question that's probably
running through your mind right now is,
how do we actually assess volatility in
order to come up with or set realistic
targets and sensible stops, stop losses?
Well, we have some spreadsheet downloads
in the downloads area to accompany this
video.
You can navigate towards the download area
and grab those spreadsheets, and we're
going to go through some examples here.
And, yes, you've guessed it, we're going
to revisit our old friends, the
distribution of returns, DOR analysis,
and from the IPLT video series, our
average true range percentage, our ATRP.
And both these analyses can be used to
help us understand volatility over our
time horizon in setting targets and stops.
So, what we're going to do here, we're
going to run through some examples.
So, the first one we're going to be
looking at is long TREX, T-R-E-X.
And we're going to make the assumption
with this example that we are looking or
seeking to enter a long position in TREX
in November 2020
at current market levels around $75, $75,
last price, $75.34.
And what we'll be doing is running through
some exercises with the distribution of
returns analysis
and steps and thought processes that you
would go through to assess the volatility
and look at setting a realistic target and
also a sensible stop loss.
In addition to that, we're not just going
to look at a long example.
We're also going to look at a short
example.
So, we're going to look at an example of
being short STZ, so Constellation Brands.
And we're going to look at shorting that
stock, look at the volatility, the
potential target,
and stop loss on entering a short position
at current market levels,
assuming that we're sitting in the time,
again, November 2020.
So, with the stock price being around
$204, last price $204.21.
So, if you've downloaded the spreadsheets
from the downloads area, let's start with
the long TREX example.
And in those spreadsheets, you can follow
along as we go through this example.
And what we've got here on the screen is
screenshots where we're looking at monthly
data.
And on the left-hand side, we've got the
close-to-close monthly returns of TREX.
And on the right-hand side, we have the
high-to-low range of monthly returns for
the same data for TREX as well.
The total count is 259 to 260 months for
the data.
And we have our distributions of the
monthly data, the historical data
displayed in the tables,
and also visually in the distribution
charts.
So, if we look at, for example, the
close-to-close monthly data for TREX,
and look at the descriptive statistics, we
have a mean, which is a positive number,
2.511%.
And we have our distribution around that
mean.
And you can see by looking at the positive
and negative data points,
that there's, in the count, more positive
months than there is negative months.
So, positive months is 139 versus negative
120.
And the average return from those 139
occurrences for a positive month is 13.1%.
And for a down month, the 120 occurrences,
we have an average return of negative
9.75%.
On a probability or frequency-adjusted
basis, in the positives, we get a
frequency-adjusted return
of just over 7% at 7.03%.
And in the negatives, on a
frequency-adjusted basis, the
frequency-adjusted return for the negative
months
is negative 4.52%.
And if you look at the distribution just
visually here, you can see that in down
months,
most of the time, in the majority of the
times, down months are occurring,
where we get a negative up to negative 6%
on the downside.
And in the positive, most months from our
data in the positive gives us a 6% to 12%
monthly return.
So, you can see these are the biggest bars
in the distribution.
Now, that's the close-to-close data.
So, taking the closing price of the
previous month versus the closing price of
a current month,
but let's turn our attention to the
high-to-low data on the right-hand side.
And remember, the high-to-low data is a
range and can occur in both down months
and up months.
And we can see here from the table and
also the descriptive statistics that Trex
is a volatile stock.
We have a high-to-low range here in the
mean on a monthly basis of 26.24%.
So, when we're actually looking at all of
this data, how do we actually disseminate
the data
and start to begin to attempt looking at
setting realistic targets and sensible
stop losses?
Well, we look at the data in the top
tables, and we look at the ranges of the
returns,
so the ranges of volatility, and we look
at the probabilities of those ranges
occurring,
and we seek to take a probabilistic
approach where the odds are in our favor.
So, let's go through this example in how
you would actually process and interpret
this data
and information in order to set realistic
targets and stops within our 20- to 60-day
time horizon.
Now, we're not going to be flicking back
to the data constantly as we go through
these numbers,
so do try to follow along at the same time
with the downloadable spreadsheets.
So, let's start here.
If you look at the data, only 14.67% of
months from the Trex data has Trex
actually moved down
by more than 12% on a close-to-close basis
in a month versus the previous month.
So, our thought process from that, if
we're taking a probabilistic approach
and wanting the odds in our favor, our
next thought would be what would happen if
we set a stop loss
of around that number, so a stop loss of
12%.
Well, we'd have an 85% chance of not being
stopped out in the next month according to
the historical data.
Now, if we then applied a 1-to-3
risk-reward ratio, this would give us a
target of 36% upside,
so a price target of 36% higher from the
current price, and we're trying to achieve
that within 60 days.
And next, we have to look at whether this
is likely or not.
And if we look at the close-to-close data,
the likelihood or probability of the stock
having a close-to-close range
on a monthly basis of positive 36% in the
first month, for example, that we have the
position on,
according to the historical data, that
probability is less than 2.32%.
So it's very unlikely.
However, if we look at the high-to-low
range data on a month-to-month basis,
we conclude that we have an 82.69% chance
of the stock having total volatility
in the range of positive 5% and plus 35%
on the month.
But remember, this also includes down
months in the data.
So putting this together, we conclude that
if we're wrong on the trade in the first
month
that we have the position on, we're
probably going to know about it very
quickly.
So it's just going to be a down month for
the stock.
Now, our fundamental thesis may or may not
be intact if that happens.
12% is probably too wide of a stop-loss
because the target of 36% is really only
achievable
if everything goes right for three months
in a row.
So 36% over three months, roughly 12% per
month.
So we're adding our cumulative
probabilities together to assess what the
likelihood of that
happening is in a particular month.
So we add 9.65%, 8.88%, plus 3.47%, plus
2.32%, and we get a 24.32% probability of
that happening,
which means the odds are against us in
getting a positive 12% return in the first
month,
and then it happening again, and then
again in the second and third month.
So the odds are against us for this to
happen to get 36% over a three-month
period.
So we have that 24.32% probability of
having a month where the stock moves up
versus last month
over 12%, and we need that to happen three
times in a row.
So what are we concluding here by just
doing our back of the envelope?
Well, we're seeking to make money here
within 60 trading days, not in a time
period that's
over 60 days with low probabilities in
place.
So what we're going to have to do here, we
have to tighten the stop loss and the
target
to make it more realistic and more
sensible.
So if we used an 8% stop and a 24% target,
this is more realistic given the
volatility assessment
that we've just been through.
We would have there between a 14.67% and
28.19% chance of being stopped out.
So around a 20% chance of being stopped
out in the first month from last month's
closing price.
So the odds of us not being stopped out,
even with an 8% stop, the odds are in our
favor.
On the upside, when it comes to our
target, by not having the pressure of
being right three
months in a row and having low probability
for that to happen, by having a 24%
target,
we would only need two months of the stock
moving up approximately 12% per month from
the current
price to meet our 24% target, and we have
a 73% chance, a 73% probability of a high
to low range
of the stock putting in 15% above a 15%
return in a month versus the previous
month.
So if you look at the cumulative
probabilities in the high to low monthly
return tables, you
can see that there's a 26.92% probability
of the stock on a month-to-month basis
moving
less than 15%.
So if we do a calculation where we minus
that of 100%, we get the probability of
73%, which
is the probability of a month-to-month
move greater than 15%.
So we have the odds in our favor that if
we're actually right and the stock does
move up, that
we'll have enough volatility to hit our
targets with a high percentage chance, a
high percentage
probability.
So as you saw from the chart earlier, the
stock was currently $75.34, so let's
assume that's
our entry price with eight and 24, that
would give us a stop loss of $69.31 and a
soft target
So from current stock price, the total
dollars for the stop loss, it's $6.03 per
share.
And the dollars for the soft target is
$18.01 per share, which gives us a risk
reward ratio
of three to one.
Now, with these price targets, so the
price target here of $93.42, what you've
actually
done here is an exercise of working out a
sensible price target over a particular
time frame, so
in our case, the 60-day time frame, and
you've worked it out on a volatility
basis.
And yes, on a volatility basis, this is a
realistic, soft price target.
But it's only obviously realistic if
you've arrived at this stage and you've
done all of
the quantitative, qualitative work as
well, and you have catalysts to drive the
stock price
higher.
What you would also do at this stage is
overlap this analysis with your
quantitative analysis
and look at the valuation appraisal of the
market and make an assumption that in the
next
period, the market pays the same multiple
or slightly higher for the earnings growth
and
or revenue growth of the company and
figure out, given the quantitative,
qualitative, and
catalyst assessment, whether this is
actually a realistic price target also
based on valuation.
So we know in this instance with Trex,
that from the current stock price to the
soft target,
it's a 24% move higher in the stock.
So from our quantitative assessment, when
we've arrived here and done our volatility
appraisal
and got a soft target, we would look at
our valuation assessment in the
quantitative, look at our qualitative
drivers and also our catalysts.
And we would base our forward-looking
valuation on a 24% move higher,
potentially in earnings per share and also
an increase in revenue and figure out if
this is actually fundamentally realistic.
And if it is, we have a nice overlap
between a volatility assessment and a
fundamental assessment, which means
overall in any situation, if we have a
realistic volatility assessment reaching a
realistic price target and we have a
realistic price target derived from a
fundamental assessment and they overlap,
then it means we have a highly probable
scenario.
So in our Trex example, let's have a look
at what this would look like on a chart.
And we fast forward three months to
February 2021.
And on the chart, we have our entry level,
which is the $75.34 level in November
2020.
We have our stop loss marked on the chart
of $69.31 and we have our target also
marked on the chart of $93.42.
And the target was reached in mid-January.
So within a couple of months.
So this was obviously a trade that went
very well.
The stop loss and the target were set at
realistic levels and the stock did
actually pretty much exactly what we
thought it was going to do in terms of
volatility.
We got the volatility appraisal right and
of course, we got the fundamental
direction right as well.
And it took just a couple of months to
reach the price target.
Now, in terms of risk management, we had
our preventative risk management in place
with our stop loss, our hard stop loss and
our preventative risk management will have
actually changed as the stock rallied.
So as the stock was rallying from the
entry price, we will have been faced with
different choices that we could make.
As a winning position, we could have just
run the position or we could have pulled
from box A and taken more risk, seeking
more risk and added to the position.
And we could have even rolled up the stock
loss in most cases, what we probably would
have done in a situation like this is we
would have rolled the stop loss when the
stock hit our soft target.
So we would have rolled the stop loss to
around 8% below the soft target price and
possibly even buy some more stock within
self-imposed single size position limits
as long as we had room to do so.
However, always remember, there's always
no one size fits all rule to all
situations here.
And that's because everything really is
situational, depending on the merits of
this specific situation itself.
Whenever you have a trade on, certainly
for the 20 to 60 day time horizon, and
you've done a lot of work around
quantitative, qualitative and catalysts,
during that time period, fundamentals can
and will likely change while you have the
trade on.
So during the lifetime of a trade, you're
going to be making assessments as the
stock either goes in your favor or goes
against you as to what has changed
fundamentally.
And your risk management is going to move
accordingly with that assessment.
So Trex is a good example of how you would
actually do your volatility assessment to
achieve a stop loss and a soft target for
a long position.
Now, let's have a look at an example where
we're looking at a short position.
And here, we're going to have a look at
Constellation Brands, ticker STZ.
Now, of course, like our Trex example, we
are making the assumption here that you've
arrived at this stage and you've done all
of your quantitative, qualitative and
catalyst assessment and also your timing.
So when you're arriving at this stage with
a short, you're very likely to have done
all of this work and come to the
conclusion that you believe this is a
negative outlier with genuine negative
catalysts about to occur and that the
stock is not only going to underperform
its peer group on the market, but it's
also going to go down in value.
And a lot of the time in financial
markets, especially when you're looking at
shorts and you're looking at companies and
stocks that have had a positive history,
but they've now gone X growth.
You're going to bump into situations where
when you analyze the data in an attempt to
appraise volatility, to get to a soft
price target to the downside and also a
hard stop loss above current prices, the
data may not show probabilities that are
highly in your favor.
Why? Because with an X growth stock, it
means that the majority of the past data
is probably positive because previously in
history, the company was actually growing
and the stock was going up.
So let's have a look at this data for
Constellation Brands STZ.
We have our usual format, same format as
our TREX example, where we have our
close-to-close monthly data on the
left-hand side and our high-to-low monthly
range data on the right-hand side.
We have our frequency and probability
tables at the top of our analysis, we have
our visual distributions, and we have our
descriptive statistics.
And if you look at the close-to-close
data, descriptive statistics, we notice
straight away the mean number is a
positive number of 1.778%.
So the average move on a month-to-month
basis, using the count of 344 months, the
average move is an up move of 1.778%.
So straight away, that's a conflicting
number with our view on the stock here,
because we're going short and we want this
stock to be going down.
If we look at this in a bit more detail,
towards the bottom of the descriptive
statistics for the close-to-close monthly
data, we can see that from the count, we
have 202 months that are positive and 139
months that are negative.
So 59% of months, roughly, we get a
positive month, and around 40-41% of
months are negative months.
So our negative months are in the
minority.
So roughly 60% of months are positive and
40% of months are negative.
And when we look at the average move for a
negative month, it comes in at 6%.
If we then turn our attention to the
high-to-low range data on the right-hand
side, we can see with the frequency and
probability data that there's a very large
grouping of below 18% for the monthly
range.
So on a month-to-month basis, the stock
not moving more than 18%, there's a very
big grouping below that number.
So if we're looking at the cumulative
percentage column, we can see that 77% of
times in history, the stock on a
month-to-month basis doesn't have
volatility.
That's above 18%.
If we look at the descriptive stats, the
mean for the high-to-low month-to-month
range is just under 15%.
So when we initially, in any situation,
look at the volatility data in tables for
any stock, this is the type of information
that our eyeballs are attracted to.
Over time, you're going to get used to
doing this.
But we're going to go through these
processes in every situation and attempt
to try and set a sensible stop-loss and a
realistic target based on our volatility
assessment and taking messages from these
numbers.
So if you have the downloaded spreadsheet
in front of you, you can follow along as
we go through this.
When we look at the close-to-close data,
you will find that 20.65% of months STZ
has moved up by more than 8% in a month
versus the previous month.
And we calculate this by highlighting the
probability on the previous screen.
So we're just adding the 10.66% and 2.33%
and we get to 20.65%.
So this tells us throughout history from
the count data that 20% of months on a
close-to-close basis, the stock goes up
more than 8%.
And therefore, 80% of the time, the stock
performance on a month-to-month basis for
close-to-close is less than 8%.
So if we, in theory, set a hard stop-loss
of 8%, we have around an 80% chance of not
being stopped out in the next month,
according to the close-to-close historical
data.
So we can conclude here that if we're just
wrong on this trade in the first month,
we're probably going to know about it very
quickly.
So it's just going to be an up month for
the stock and we're probably going to be
very close to being stopped out or getting
stopped out.
Now, if we apply our one-to-three
risk-reward, this would give us 24% upside
on the trade, which translates into,
obviously, because it's a short 24%
downside in the stock as our price target
within 60 days.
So if we look at the table again, the
likelihood or probability of the stock
having a close-to-close range that's above
24% in the first month, so the month
upcoming, is less than 2.33%.
So that's very unlikely.
So we turn to the right-hand side of our
data and we look at the high to low
volatility range at this stage to get an
appreciation of what the total volatility
is on a month-to-month basis.
And we note at this stage that for the
stock, according to the historical data,
for the stock to have a 9% move or
greater, and we just take note at this
stage that for the stock to have a high to
low range that's greater than 9%,
according to the historical monthly data,
that's happened 75.65% of times.
And the way this is worked out is that we
look at the cumulative column and we look
at the cumulative probability of all of
the months in the count where the range
has been lower than 9%, and we minus this
off 100% to get the 75.65%.
So we're starting to build up a picture
here from the volatility profile of the
stock about what might not just be
possible, but what is actually probable.
Now, from our potential 24% target to the
downside, from the data, we're obviously
concluding that we're going to need two to
three months of the stock going down
between 8%, so that's over three months,
so 8% per month, and 12% over two months.
So 12% going down each month, so 12% or
two months to meet the price target of the
stock being down 24% within the
three-month time period.
Now, these numbers on a month to month
basis are obviously approximate, but when
we do this as a back of the envelope, and
then we look at the data for the stock to
close lower by more than 8% on the
previous month, we're actually presented
with a probability of 12.21%.
So, again, this is unlikely.
So, what do we actually conclude from this
when we do the volatility appraisal in the
context of our potential trade idea here,
our potential position?
Well, for the short to work, we would
actually need the high to low volatility
to play out to the downside within the
month.
However, in the upcoming month, if the
stock is down by more than 8% on the
month, the likelihood of it closing on the
month below that price is 12.21%
probability.
What we're going to need here is a
fundamental shift or change in the stock
to the downside.
So, the stock has an abnormal move to the
downside during the next month.
Because to justify why we're in the short,
we actually need it to stay down and have
the same bad performance the following
month.
And this is fine as long as we have
identified an X growth stock and we have
negative catalysts that are occurring.
So, our fundamental thesis is actually
intact and we have the catalysts.
Of course, we can put the trade on.
But obviously, because this is potentially
an X growth stock here, the past data is
giving us low probabilities of outcomes
for reasonable moves down in the stock.
So, if you think back to our fundamental
framework, when we're looking at shorts
and also when we looked at our different
phases, so our five phases of a short,
what we're trying to do here is pick X
growth stocks that are in phase two and
phase three, ideally.
And from a volatility appraisal
perspective, what we're wanting to happen
is for the stock to essentially break the
historical data and to have abnormal moves
to the downside.
So, we're looking for a cluster of two to
three months of data to the downside.
And you can see now why it's very
important that you have to be very
confident with your shorts in terms of the
fundamental analysis, the catalysts, and
even the timing.
And you can see why it's so important why
we try to catch our shorts as X growth in
phase two and phase three, because if we
catch them in phase two and phase three,
these are abnormal moves and we're more
than likely to get abnormal returns from
those abnormal moves.
Additionally, what you also have to
understand here is our mandate as
long-short portfolio managers, we
absolutely do need to have shorts in our
account.
We can't just be long everything all the
time.
That's not our mandate.
So, it's likely in periods of economic
expansion when you're looking for shorts
that when you look at the historical
month-to-month data,
you're going to bump into many situations
like this, like STZ, where the past data
is in conflict with your short trade idea.
And this is exactly why it's so hard to
find high-quality shorts in an
expansionary economy and when the stock
market is in a bull market.
You are constantly looking for those large
and mega-cap shorts that have turned a
corner and have gone X growth and are in
now phase two or phase three.
To have the conflicting historical data
there is fine as long as your fundamental
thesis is intact and you're timing these
trades well in terms of the phase that
you're going in to the short.
Of course, it goes without saying, but
I'll say it anyway, that it's a genuine
fundamental shift because when that
happens, the past data doesn't actually
mean anything.
So, if we were going into this short
shorting STZ in November 2020, what would
this have looked like from a stop-loss and
target perspective?
Well, we've got our 8% stop and our 24%
soft target and we know from the past data
that with an 8% stop, we have about a 20%
chance of being stopped out in the first
month.
And we're comfortable with that because if
we do get stopped out, it just means we're
dead wrong.
And we've stopped ourselves from being
human and fighting the market.
We also know that to reach our target,
approximately, we're going to need two to
three months of the stock moving down by
8% or 12% per month to meet the target
from here.
But if we do get the direction right, we
do have the volatility available to us.
We have a 75.5% chance of getting 9% and
above high to low range in terms of the
volatility.
So, if we do get the direction right here,
the volatility historically does actually
exist.
So, to get our numbers, to get our
stop-loss and our target in terms of stock
price dollars, we take the current stock
price in November 2020, $204.21.
We apply the 8% stop-loss.
This gives us a stop-loss of $220.54.
And then applying the three-for-one, the
24% target to the downside, our soft
target to the downside.
This gives us $155.20.
So, on a per share basis, for the stop,
this is $16.33 per share for the
stop-loss.
And for the target, $49.01 for the target
per share.
And just to double-check the numbers, we
divide the target by the stop-loss, and
this gives us a three-for-one.
So, let's fast-forward in time and see how
this one actually worked out.
Well, we fast-forward to February 2021,
and unfortunately, this one, short STZ,
didn't work out.
So, we would have entered the short
position towards the end of November in
2020,
and then we would have been stopped out at
the beginning of January in 2021.
So, we would have lost $16.33 per share.
So, it kind of lines up with the
volatility appraisal that we did.
We didn't get stopped out in the first
month, so we had a sensible stop-loss.
It was wide enough to give us a chance at
being right,
but it wasn't too wide where we were being
reckless, stupid, and being human.
So, we got stopped out at the beginning of
the second month that the trade was on.
So, entering in November, towards the end
of November,
and we would have been stopped out on the
position on January 6th.
And when you think of STZ in the context
of a portfolio and in the context of our
previous example with Trex,
this now leads us into discussing another
topic and raises some issues with hard
stop-losses.
So, imagine a situation where you have a
portfolio and you decide to put hard
stop-losses on all of your longs and on
all of your shorts.
We do need to use some sort of stops in
our portfolio to counter our tendency
towards human behavior.
However, hard stops in a long-short
portfolio do also have limitations.
So, imagine this situation if you have a
portfolio of 10 positions with, say, 6
longs and 4 shorts,
and you have a net-long portfolio bias.
So, in that situation, very likely that
you've got that type of profile in your
portfolio.
So, as the economy is expanding, revenue
and EPS estimates across the market are
rising on average,
and the stock market is rallying.
You still need to have, though, shorts in
your portfolio.
However, with hard stop-losses, we could
be in a position every 2 to 3 months
during an expansionary phase
where we just keep getting stopped out of
short positions
and running long-only trading accounts,
which is obviously not our mandate.
So, we simply can't allow this to happen.
If we get caught too long when the market
has a drawdown period and sells off,
and we have no short positions on, then
we're going to lose big money when the
market does go down.
It's our job when the market goes down to
make money in all market conditions.
So, we have to make money when the market
goes down as well.
Now, Chris Quill is going to look at this
in more detail in the next part of the PTM
video series.
However, one step that we can take is to
actually apply spread stops.
So, if you recall from earlier on in the
PTM video series, when we looked at
spreads,
we looked at minusing the value of one
stock off another
and looking at the outperformance and
underperformance of two stocks relative to
each other.
And if you recall, the value of a
portfolio is simply the outperformance
versus the underperformance of a whole
bunch of stocks.
So, when it comes to hard stop losses and
soft targets, because at any one moment in
time,
even though we do try to control
correlation in our portfolios,
correlation is likely to be present.
Some sort of correlation will be there in
our portfolios.
And when the market goes up and down and
all stocks move in the same direction
together,
we just never want to be in a situation,
for example, where we're running a
long-short portfolio.
The market goes up 10%.
We get stopped out on hard stop losses on
all of our shorts.
And then we're naked long.
We just have longs in our portfolio.
And then the market goes back down 10%.
And then we get stopped out on all of our
longs,
because that means we will lose money on
all our positions.
And in that situation, we're essentially
in a long-short portfolio being whipsawed
by the market.
And the end result is that you'll blow up.
So, setting spread stops and targets
within your portfolio is a good way to
minimize this impact and to remedy this
situation.
Now, there is no rulebook here.
Remember, there will be situations from
time to time where it's sensible to use a
hard stop loss on a position.
But there will be other times when it's
sensible to use spread stop losses and
also potentially portfolio stop losses.
Everything is situational and what's more
important here is that you understand why
you would use them and then learn how to
appraise volatility and the situations
themselves and just use common sense.
Unfortunately, we can't give you an
instruction manual or a rulebook which
tells you in all situations to impose a
hard stop loss, a spread stop loss, or to
have a portfolio stop loss of a certain
amount all the time.
So, if you feel at any moment in time, as
a trader, long-short portfolio manager,
that you're screaming at the sky, howling
at the moon, asking, what do I do here?
Do I set a hard stop loss?
Do I set a spread stop loss?
What shall I do?
Somebody please tell me what to do.
You're taking the wrong approach.
You're doing it wrong.
You need to look at the volatility
appraisal of the stock.
You'll have a portfolio where you've
already done the volatility appraisal of
other stocks.
You'll compare this to your valuation
work, your quantitative assessment, and
your qualitative assessment and catalysts,
and you're going to apply common sense to
the numbers.
And as long as you take an approach where
you're setting realistic targets on a
single stock or a spread, and also setting
sensible stop losses, where you're giving
yourself a very reasonable chance of
staying in the position and making money
within the 20 to 60 day time horizon.
So the stop losses are wide enough to
enable that to happen, but at the same
time, they're not too wide that you're
being dishonest and reckless.
If you take that approach overall, and you
learn the process and understand the
numbers and apply common sense over many
trades, over a long period of time, you're
going to get it right most of the time
with practice, and you're going to add
value in terms of your preventative risk
management in not allowing yourself to be
human.
So let's have a look at this.
So let's have a look at this Trex STZ
spread.
And what we've done here is we've minused
the STZ stock price off the Trex stock
price.
So recall, we're going long Trex and short
STZ, and something you would likely do
when you're looking at a spread, you would
look at the outperformance,
underperformance of the two stocks over a
longer period of time, just to get an
understanding and appreciation of what the
relationship of the two stocks has been
like over time.
Some things to note here, when we look at
the data of this spread on the chart, Trex
is colored in white, STZ is colored in
orange, and we've normalized these stock
prices starting at an index value of 100
in February 2020.
And this one-year chart, which takes us up
to February 2021, shows Trex and STZ in
absolute terms, and their index and
percentage performance.
So we can see, when we look at Trex, the
white line, the Trex index hit a high of
215 spot 81, and is currently at 208 spot
36.
And that translates into a performance
over the one-year period of 108%.
The STZ data was starting again at the
level, index level of 100.
The index got to a high of 127 spot 57,
currently 118.
So STZ over that one-year period was up
18%.
If we look at the spread data at the
bottom, so this is where we're taking the
STZ stock price and minusing it off the
market.
Trex stock price, overall, we get a
negative number because STZ, the stock
price for STZ, is larger than the Trex
stock price.
But because this is Trex minus STZ, when
Trex is outperforming STZ, this spread,
although it's a minus number, is going up
in value.
So moving closer to zero, closer to the
positive.
And when Trex is underperforming STZ, it's
going more negative.
We look at our high and low data just for
a reference point.
So we can see that this spread traded at a
low in February 2020 of 155.
So in the one-year period, this is the
most extreme point at where Trex was
underperforming STZ.
And then we have our high of minus 72 in
March 2020, which is the most extreme
point where Trex was outperforming STZ.
And we just make note of that with a bit
of common sense here and stock market
historical knowledge.
This was around a period of extreme
volatility during COVID times.
So prior to the COVID sell-off, we had
Trex underperforming STZ.
And at the bottom of the COVID sell-off,
we had Trex massively outperforming STZ.
And this was really due to the nature of
the businesses.
Trex is in the business of wood decking
and railing.
And STZ, Constellation Brands, is an
alcoholic beverage producer.
And the spread, if we fast forward to the
full end of year, one year of this data,
to February 2021,
we can see the value of the spread is
negative $120.
Now, let's assume we are now sitting in
November 2020, so on November 19th, 2020.
And obviously, right now, we have the
benefit of hindsight of knowing what
actually happened to those stock prices
and the relative performance.
But at the time, on November 19th, we just
obviously would not have known any of that
information.
And we would have had to have just gone on
the historical analysis of the spread.
And of course, we wouldn't have even
arrived here unless we'd have done all of
our fundamental work
and genuinely thought that Trex was a long
and STZ was a short.
And if we look back previous to November
19th, this is what we would have been
looking at.
And we would see that overall, from the
start date in February 2020, where we
indexed to 100,
that there is a trend in our favor that
Trex is outperforming STZ.
But if we look at the chart at the bottom,
the actual dollar value of the spread,
we can see that between April 2020 and
October 2020, the spread was trading
within a range of the value,
negative $120 to negative $100.
And then in November 2020, the spread
breaks the negative $120 level to the
downside.
And then we are sitting at November 19th
with the spread at around negative $130.
And we have decisions to make on our
execution and how we enter this with
preventative risk management in place.
So, on November 19th, we're basically
looking at a level of a negative $130 on
the spread.
And we have to now do our work and
understand the volatility of the
individual stocks
and the potential for the spread to move.
And we've already done our distribution of
returns analysis.
And we understand the probability and odds
of the stocks individually of returning
certain amounts
within time periods of a month and being
right over a period of one, two, and three
months.
So, the thought process here, when we're
thinking about our work on the
distribution of returns analysis
on the individual stocks and our work on
analyzing the spread itself historically,
we would probably just be thinking to
ourselves and doing a back of the envelope
of applying a 10% stop roughly
and a 30% target for our three-for-one and
just looking at what that looks like on
the spread itself.
So, if we applied a 10% stop to a negative
$130 spread price, that's going to be a
stop of $13,
which on a three-for-one gives us a target
of $39.
So, taking off $13 from the spread value
of approximately negative $130 gives us a
stop loss on the spread of negative $143.
And adding $39 to negative $130 gives us a
target of $91.
So, your thought process here, when you're
sitting at these points in time,
before you actually do the actual and
exact calculations would be to do a back
of the envelope
and just look at what would be a
reasonable and sensible stop loss and
target given all of the information that's
available.
And then just question whether it is
reasonable or sensible.
So, we're sitting at a value here of
negative $130.
If we applied a stop loss on the spread of
negative $143, if we look at that spread
data at the bottom of the chart,
it probably means that we're just dead
wrong on the spread and we should be
stopping ourselves out.
Also, with the target, if we're sitting
there on November 19th and we're adding
$39 for our target to get to negative $91,
we have to ask ourselves, is this within
the bounds of reality?
Well, it's a 30% move in the spread.
And given the distribution of returns
analysis that we did earlier, where we had
targets of 24% on TREX and 24% on STZ,
we concluded that the move, that type of
move for TREX was highly probable if we
get the direction right in terms of the
volatility.
However, with STZ, that type of move would
only be possible if we got a genuine
fundamental break,
fundamental shift to the downside for the
short.
When we look at the spread value itself,
we do have evidence over the last year,
obviously,
that this spread has traded to a high of
negative $72.15.
But we do have to be intellectually honest
here and realize that during that period,
it was a high volatility period generally
in the market.
So over the next 20 to 60-day time
horizon, if we're sitting there on
November 19th and we just assume normal
volatility generally in the market,
we have to ask ourselves, is the stop-loss
sensible and is the target within the
bounds of reality?
Well, it is as long as we get a
fundamental break to the upside in TREX
and or we get a fundamental break to the
downside in STZ.
It can very obviously happen if we get
that, but if general market conditions are
normal and volatility is normal,
we just have to be intellectually honest
with ourselves that we're probably going
to have to be active and take actions on
the spread itself.
What do we mean by that?
Well, it basically means if one of these
positions, whether it's the long or the
short side of the spread,
presents itself as a winner, it means
adding to the winner.
And if the other side presents itself as a
loser, we reduce the losing position.
So this is the thought process that we're
probably going to be going through in most
situations,
just applying a back of the envelope given
a distribution of returns analysis to a
spread
and applying some sensible and realistic
expectations and sensible and realistic
stops and targets
and having a plan of action, not just for
our preventative risk management,
but also for our reactive risk management
as the trade evolves.
So we actually have a plan going into the
trade.
So let's have a look at the numbers and
figure out the evolution of this trade
and the likely outcomes and actions we may
have taken.
So at the start of the period on November
19, 2020, the TREX stock price was $73.58
and the STZ stock price was $204.21.
And this gives us a spread value of
negative $130.63.
If we applied a 10% stop loss to the
negative $130.63, this would give us a
stop loss level of $143.69.
We know by looking at the spread chart
that this is a pretty sensible stop loss
in that it's wide enough to give us a
chance at making money,
but not wide enough that we're being human
and running a losing position
and seeking risk in a losing situation.
So pulling from box A, where we either
continue to run that position or even
worse, add to it.
If we apply our three-for-one of $13.69 on
a three-for-one,
gives us $41.07, which gives us a target
of $89.56.
Is that in the realms of possibility?
Yes, it is.
But it would have to, the spread would
have to trade back towards March 2020
levels
within the next 20 to 60 days.
Is it probable only if we're highly
confident that either Trex or STZ or even
both of them
are going to have a fundamental shift in
the direction that we're calling?
And then how did this spread actually end
up in February 2021?
Well, we know the outcome here.
So if we did enter at the level on
November 19 at negative $130.63,
by February, the trade would have been
showing a profit having done absolutely
nothing.
So taking no actions at all on either
stock, a profit of $10.03, or a return of
7.67%.
So of course, this doesn't assume any
actions taken at all on the spread,
like adding to Trex and or reducing STZ.
So if you recall, when we looked at hard
stops and soft targets on the individual
stocks and
not on the spread, we had a soft target in
Trex of $93.42 and a soft target in STZ of
$155.20.
In a situation like this, which can be
quite typical in periods of normal
volatility
and normal market conditions, what we
would likely be doing is looking at the
winning side of a spread
when we have the positions on.
And when the winning side of the spread
hits our soft target,
we would revert to a hard stop and new
target or price target 2 on the winning
position itself
in the same way or the same action that we
highlighted earlier
when we looked at Trex hitting its soft
target of $93.42
and applying the 8% stop loss below the
soft target,
which at the time would have been the
current stock price.
And we would probably be adding to that
position.
And at the same time, if the short is just
a losing position,
we would probably be seeking to reduce the
size of that position.
So what we've done here is entered a long
and a short
with a stop loss on the spread and a
target on the spread.
But when the winning side of the trade
presents itself,
we've added to the winning side of the
trade
and we've reduced the position size of the
losing side of the trade.
And we've applied both hard stop losses
and soft targets on both sides of the
trade
at the same time.
Now, of course, with our example with Trex
and STZ,
this spread example, it was the long side
of the trade
that was the winning side of the trade
and the short that was the losing side of
the trade.
There very obviously, through time,
through many trades,
will be situations where that's reversed.
So you will put on spread trades where the
long side ends up being the losing side
and the short side ends up being the
winning side.
But the same approach applies that we've
just been through.
If you have a situation where you've
entered a spread,
the spread goes in your favor.
But what's driving the value of the spread
is the winning side on the short side.
When the short side gets to a level of a
soft target,
which you've calculated from your
distribution of returns analysis
on the absolute value of the stock,
you would just take a similar action where
you would add to the short,
reduce the long, the size of the long
position,
and you would add hard stop losses and
targets to the new positions.
Now, when we look at this spread,
we can actually categorize our example
spread as a cross-sector spread trade.
So Trex, $8 billion market cap,
wood decking and railing sector,
and Constellation Brands, $42 billion
large cap.
It's an alcoholic beverages producer.
So you can see this fits our remit of
being long mid-cap stocks
and short large-cap stocks.
And when you're building these portfolios,
the example that we've just been through
can be quite typical in normal market
conditions
and in normal expansionary economic
conditions.
And this is why we've used this example.
So in the future, you know how to deal
with these situations.
If we end up in a situation where we have
a market reversal
and you have a net long portfolio
where you have a number of mid-cap longs
versus large-cap shorts,
you need to make sure that you have your
preventative risk management in place
and you're actually active.
So you're applying reactive risk
management.
It's not good enough, as mentioned
previously,
to just have a situation where you have
hard stop losses on all of your longs
and you get stopped out on all of your
longs
and then you get caught out because you
have no longs in your portfolio
and the market goes up and you get
squeezed on all of your short positions.
By the same token, it's not good enough to
have a situation where your long mid-caps,
short large caps overall.
And in an expansionary phase, the market
keeps going up.
You have hard stop losses on all your
shorts.
You get stopped out on all your shorts.
And then the market goes back down and all
of your longs go down in value.
This means you're just being whipsawed.
You're opening yourself up to potential
large losses in your portfolio.
And it's very obviously not a sensible
approach to apply right across the board.
So this is why we've shown you this
example here,
where when you're entering positions,
you can enter them initially by applying a
hard stop loss on spreads.
So the relative outperformance and
underperformance,
where you trade into both and trade out of
both at the same time at hard stop losses.
And if the individual stocks themselves,
one presents itself as a winner,
one presents itself as a loser, you add to
the winner and reduce the loser.
And again, guys, there is no absolute rule
book here.
We really can't give you an instruction
manual on what to do in every situation,
in every stock, in every spread forever
into the future.
Preventative risk management practices
when put in place,
stop you from being human.
That's what we're trying to do here.
But at the same time, they do have
limitations.
And you have to be reactive as well.
And reactive risk management just comes
down to experience.
So real money trading and being involved
in multiple situations like this over
time.
So you can just as easily not have hard
stop losses on the single stock positions
themselves and have what we call a mental
stop loss on a spread within your
portfolio with also mental targets.
Then you can seek to add to your winners,
so pulling from box A, and reduce your
losers, pulling from box B, when the
single stocks break out or break down and
also add hard stop losses at the same
time.
So if you recall, with our example, TREX
and STZ, our soft target in absolute terms
when we did our distribution of returns
analysis for TREX was $93.42.
And when the stock actually gets to around
that level, we could, for example, just
add to the TREX and reduce the STZ at the
same time.
And the reason why we do that at the same
time is because both positions are
contingent on each other.
We are trading the relative outperformance
and underperformance of two stocks
relative to each other.
So when we take an action on one side,
we're normally taking an action on the
other side.
That's just best practice.
Now, what's interesting from a data
perspective, what you can actually do is
use the distribution of returns analysis
that we've shown you throughout the PTM
video series and the IPLT video series.
You can repeat this for the spread data as
well using Excel, and you can calculate a
reasonable hard stop and soft target for
the spread over the one to three month
period.
However, what you have to remember here is
that in reality, in practice, when you're
doing this for real, in your trading
accounts, no brokerage platforms allow
spread, stop losses, and targets to be
applied on the platform.
So you have to apply what we call mental
stops and targets and do everything
yourself.
So the best way to do this would be to
obviously record your stops and targets in
a spreadsheet, save them on file.
And if a spread does actually trade at
your hard stop loss on the spread, you
have to go into the brokerage platform and
trade out of both sides of the position.
Conversely, when one of your winners
presents itself and gets to an absolute
soft target, you have to go into your
brokerage platform and take action on that
position and also take action on the other
side of the spread as well.
So you would be most likely, in all
probability, remember, this is not a rule,
so don't follow this as a rule.
You would probably, most likely, be adding
to the winning side of a spread and
reducing the losing side of a spread.
And in the event that you have a situation
where the spread itself reaches the soft
target for the entire spread, you have to
assess this situation where you look at
both sides of the spread and determine
which action is the most likely situation
you're going to be taking.
Because it could be the case that one side
of the spread is driving the value of the
entire spread and you have one winner and
one loser or one winner and one stock is
flat.
But you may have two winners as well and
you may even want to add to both sides of
the spread.
Again, this is all situational and now
we're getting into reactive risk
management, which unfortunately just can't
be taught in a video series.
It has to be taught for real or you have
to build up your experience over time in
understanding the actions that you would
take in particular situations.
It really does just come down to getting
live coaching, live mentoring and or
building up your experience for reactive
risk management.
But with preventative risk management,
it's all very straightforward.
We put preventative risk management
parameters in place like hard stops and
soft targets on single stock positions and
also on spreads through volatility
analysis and valuation analysis.
And this stops us from being human so we
don't take actions in our trading account
that are going to hurt us in the long
term.
Now, in this video, as we've been looking
at hard stop losses and soft targets and
also obviously our trading psychology as
to why we even have them in place,
we do have another method of calculating
hard stop losses and soft targets in
addition to the distribution of returns
analysis.
We have the ATRP, the average true range
percentage analysis that we've looked at
previously in the PTM and in the IPLT
video series.
And we can use this to set hard stop
losses and soft targets as well.
And the ATRP is a quicker analysis than
the distribution of returns analysis.
ATRP gets us to quick answers and decent
rough estimates for one to three month
volatility in setting sensible stop losses
and realistic soft targets.
So we're not saying here that it presents
a shortcut.
You should really be seeking to do both
the ATRP analysis and the distribution of
returns analysis.
But admittedly, ATRP does get you to some
pretty accurate answers.
But the distribution of returns analysis
really does confirm the data, even though
it's a longer and more tedious process to
go through,
especially if trading is not actually your
full time job.
So for retail traders, part time traders,
ATRP is good enough.
But if you do have the time or you do
actually want to go and work in the
industry,
really knowing how to do the distribution
of returns analysis is going to help you
that little bit more.
And that's the reason why we've been
through the distribution of returns
analysis in this video.
So you fully understand the process.
And what's going to happen next is that
Chris Quill is going to go through a
spreadsheet class,
both with the distribution of returns
analysis and the ATRP analysis in setting
hard stop losses and soft targets.
So by the end of the next video, you will
understand the technicalities and the data
dynamics of both approaches.
And what we've done here on the screen,
you can see the ATRP analysis for both
TREX and STZ,
where we're trying to get an appreciation
of volatility within the one to three
month time horizon.
And in the top row boxes, you can see that
for both stocks, we're using weekly data.
And this helps us to set and understand a
potential hard stop loss for both the
individual stocks themselves and for the
spread.
And in the bottom row, you can see the
bottom row tables, you can see we're using
quarterly data over longer time horizons,
which helps us understand the volatility
within that time horizon parameter of a
quarter,
which helps us in setting realistic
targets for the 60 day time horizon,
not only for the individual stocks
themselves, but also for a spread.
So in the next video, Chris is actually
going to go through this with you.
So you understand it in a bit more detail.
So this has been a pretty long video,
pretty intense in terms of the amount of
information to take in.
So let's summarize here.
We started off by showing you exactly why
we would have stop losses and targets in
place at any one time in our portfolio.
And that is down to human psychology.
And pulling from box A and pulling from
box B at the right times is absolutely
critical to our long term trading success.
Without stop losses, some sort of stop
loss across our portfolio positions and
targets across our portfolio of positions,
without stops and targets in place, we
open ourselves up to becoming victims of
human psychology.
We can have tons and tons of good trade
ideas and our timing can actually be quite
good.
However, if we don't have a genuine
understanding of a stock's volatility
within our 20 to 60 day time horizon
and the odds of being stopped out or
hitting our targets,
then essentially we are trading blind and
we are trading without having a plan.
If you do put yourself in that situation
when there's no understanding of any of
this
and there's no plan in place, when a stock
is moving around every day, week to week,
you may get sucked in to being a human
being and doing stupid things.
Now, as mentioned several times, and
because of its importance,
this point cannot be labored enough.
Unfortunately, there is no
one-size-fits-all model for setting hard
stops and targets.
So we are not telling you here that there
is a solution for all situations.
There's not a rule book.
There just isn't.
Everything is situational.
In a long-short portfolio and in any
market, it's about outperformance and
underperformance of the assets that you're
going long and short.
However, you always have to remember that
we are absolute return traders and we want
to make money when markets go both up and
down.
That means on the way up, if we know
there's a good chance that we're going to
get stopped out on shorts,
we have to be active and take actions.
So we can either get better shorts that we
think will actually go down,
so not sitting like a rabbit in the
headlights and falling into a trap of just
having a trading account that's full of
lazy shorts as potential hedges.
We can decide on many occasions not to use
hard stop losses and use spread or ratio
stop losses.
Or if we are using a hard stop loss or
hard stop losses in a lot of positions in
our account,
we can replace them if we get stopped out
on, for example, shorts with better
shorts.
Now, of course, the reverse applies.
So if the market is going down, the same
best practices apply to long positions in
a bear market.
Now, if you think about a situation where
you already have a live portfolio in place
and you're thinking about adding a
position to that portfolio,
then it's a pretty straightforward
exercise to model spread and ratio stops
and implement them when you already have a
live portfolio.
So, for example, when you're planning to
add a short position to a portfolio,
you can select a long position in the
portfolio
and work out the stop and target for the
spread and then take them off together.
If the spread stop is hit and or you can
run the whole spread as it moves in your
favor
and you can potentially add to the whole
spread.
You can add to the winning side of the
spread and reduce a losing side of the
spread.
You can revert to hard stop losses on the
stock prices individually
or you can roll the stop loss on the
entire spread.
It should be obvious now that there's
multiple things you can do
and that there is no rulebook here that
fits all situations perfectly.
This is a judgment call that has to be
made by you on the situation itself at the
time.
You have to focus on the process here so
you get good at appraising volatility
and setting sensible stop losses and
reasonable targets, realistic targets
and then just implement these processes
over many situations over a long period of
time
so you get the experience.
Above all else, you just have to be
intellectually honest with yourself
about the statistical data and implement
the plan
that's most likely to be optimal for risk
versus reward.
So guys, obviously a lot to take in there
in terms of human psychology, trader
psychology
and also stops and targets, preventative
risk management.
You've now got a very good understanding
of the theory behind all of this
and also having a look at some practical
examples,
understanding how it works in practice.
What we're going to do now is go over to
Chris Quill in the next video
and what Chris is going to show you,
he's going to give you a spreadsheet class
on how to actually calculate
distribution of returns and ATRP
in order to assess volatility for setting
hard stops and targets
for single stock positions and mental
stops and targets for spreads and also
portfolio stop losses.
Chris is going to obviously use real data
in his analysis,
but what he'll be doing is using a
theoretical long short stock portfolio
to just highlight the preventative risk
management steps that you can take and
engage in
to limit your dollar losses and maximize
dollar gains.
So essentially to maximize your R score in
your trading accounts.
So what he's also going to go through is
preventative risk management measures
like gross exposure limits, cash for cash
net exposure limits,
and beta adjusted net exposure limits.
And on top of that, he's also going to set
out some realistic long term targets for
your R score
and your percentage win rate and
percentage loss rate.
So you're going to get a full statistical
masterclass here in preventative risk
management.
So instead of going back to the desk at
this stage,
let's just shoot straight into the next
video
and I'll see you at the end of the next
video.
you're going to go ahead and see you at
the end of the next video.
I'll see you at the end of the next video.
You'll see you at the end of the next
video.
I'll see you at the end of the next video.
You'll see you at the end of the next
video.
I'll see you at the end of the next video.